this afternoon
I welcomed president vondoline to
Windsor to continue our discussions
about the Northern Ireland protocol
I'm pleased to report
that we have now made a decisive
breakthrough
together
we have changed the original protocol
and are today announcing the New Windsor
framework
today's agreement
delivers smooth flowing trade within the
whole United Kingdom
protects Northern Ireland's place in our
Union
and safeguards sovereignty for the
people of Northern Ireland
now these negotiations have not always
been easy
but I'd like to pay an enormous personal
tribute to Ursula for her vision in
recognizing the possibility of a new way
forward
and to my colleagues the foreign and
Northern Ireland secretaries for their
steadfast leadership
the United Kingdom and European Union
may have had our differences in the past
but we are allies
trading partners and Friends something
that we've seen clearly in the past year
as we joined with others to support
Ukraine
this is the beginning of a new chapter
in our relationship
for a quarter of a century the Belfast
Good Friday agreement has endured
because at its heart
is respect for the aspirations and
identity of all communities
today's agreement is about preserving
that delicate balance and charting a new
way forward for the people of Northern
Ireland
I am standing here today
because I believe we have found ways to
end the uncertainty and challenge for
the people of Northern Ireland
we have taken three big steps forward
first today's agreement delivers the
smooth flow of trade within the United
Kingdom Goods destined for Northern
Ireland will travel through a new Green
Lane with a separate red lane for Goods
at risk of moving onto the EU
in the Green Lane burdensome Customs
bureaucracy will be scrapped it means
food retailers like supermarkets
restaurants and wholesalers will no
longer need hundreds of certificates for
every lorry
and we will end the situation where food
made to UK rules could not be sent to
and sold in Northern Ireland
this means that if food is available on
Supermarket shelves in Great Britain
then it will be available on Supermarket
shelves in Northern Ireland
and unlike the protocol today's
agreement means people sending Parcels
to friends or family or doing their
shopping online
will have to complete no Customs
paperwork
this means we have removed any sense of
a border in the Irish sea
second we have protected Northern
Ireland's place in the Union
we've amended the legal text of the
protocol to ensure we can make critical
vat and excise changes for the whole of
the UK for example on alcohol Duty
meaning our reforms to cut the cost of a
pint in the pub will now apply in
Northern Ireland
the same quintessentially British
products like trees plants and seed
potatoes will again be available in
Northern Ireland's garden centers
onerous travels on pet requirements have
been removed
and today's agreement also delivers a
landmark settlement on medicines
from now on drugs are proved for use by
the UK's medicines regulator will be
automatically available in every
Pharmacy and Hospital in Northern
Ireland
but
today's agreement safeguards sovereignty
for the people of Northern Ireland
the only EU law that applies in Northern
Ireland under the framework is the
minimum necessary to avoid a hard border
with Ireland and allow Northern Irish
businesses to continue accessing the EU
Market
but I know that many people in Northern
Ireland are worried about being subject
to changes in EU Goods laws
to address that today's agreement
introduces a new Stormont break
many had called for Stormont to have a
say over these laws
but the storm won't break goes further
and means that stormwalk can in fact
stop them from applying in Northern
Ireland
this will establish a clear process
through which the democratically elected
assembly can pull an emergency break for
changes to EU Goods rules that would
have significant and lasting effects on
everyday lives
if the break is pulled the UK government
will have a veto
this gives the institutions of the Good
Friday agreement in Northern Ireland a
powerful new Safeguard based on
cross-community consent
I believe the Windsor framework marks a
turning point for the people of Northern
Ireland it fixes the Practical problems
they face it preserves the balance of
the Belfast Good Friday agreement
now of course parties will want to
consider the agreement in detail a
process that will need time and care
today's agreement is written in the
language of laws and treaties
but really
it's about much more than that
it's about stability in Northern Ireland
it's about real people
and real businesses
it's about showing that our Union that
has lasted for centuries can and will
endure
and it's about breaking down the
barriers between us
setting aside the arguments that for too
long have divided us
and remembering that fellow feeling that
defines us this family of Nations
this United Kingdom